welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is Professor Philip Gorski a
professor of sociology and co-director
of the Center for comparative research
at Yale professor Gorski is a
comparative historical sociologist and
his research focuses on topics such as
state formation nationalism revolution
economic development and secularization
with particular attention to the
interaction of religion and politics
which leads us to the topic we will be
discussing today civil religion
welcome professor Gorski thank you very
much Marilyn so what is civil religion
well civil religion is a way of thinking
about what the proper relationship
between religion and politics should be
and I think to get a full sense of what
civil religion is it's helpful if we
come at it from a number of different
angles so one way of thinking about it
is if we imagine religion and politics
as sort of separate spheres or systems
with within a society we can imagine
them having different relationships to
one another civil religion understands
that relationship is one of being
relative autonomy which is to say that
they're that they're distinct systems
but they have an area of overlap between
them and this sets it apart for example
from what might be called liberal
secularism or total separation ISM which
says that religion politics should have
absolutely nothing to do with one
another and it also sets it apart from
what I call religious nationalism which
is the notion that the religious and the
political communities should be exactly
the same another way of thinking about
it is historically because in any
particular country civil religion will
be
a particular tradition that draws on a
certain stock of symbols and stories and
rituals and what exactly is in that
toolkit is something that is the product
of a specific national history so in the
case of American civil religion I see it
as having two main sources what I would
call the covenant theology of the
Puritans and the Civic republicanism of
the founding fathers now what do i what
do I mean by covenant theology but many
of the original Puritan theologians and
preachers imagined the u.s. or at least
New England as a kind of a new Israel
that is as a sort of a chosen people
that had a sacred covenant with God and
that if they remain true to that
covenant God would remain bound to them
and would bless them and if they
deviated from that covenant they would
be rebuked and punished and and scolded
the Civic Republican tradition of the
founding fathers envisioned the United
States more as a new Athens if you will
and their fundamental notion was that
the success of the American experiment
in democracy and self-government
required not just good institutions but
required also a virtuous citizenry and
what they understood by virtue was
really two things one sort of a
willingness to take bold action on
behalf of the community but also a kind
of cultivation of self-restraint and
self-discipline they saw these as really
sort of two sides of the same coin
interestingly I think that these two
traditions although certainly
historically distinct are actually very
complementary to one another there's
certain places in which in which they
converge and in particular on two points
one the notion that that
community is more just than the sum of
individuals that it has a certain kind
of reality of its own and that the sort
of health and survival of a vigorous
political Republican political community
requires certain kinds of the
cultivation of certain kinds of moral
virtues on the part of part of the
population and these two things I think
have been largely blended together then
in America and American history the
third and final way that I would
approach civil religion is as a certain
kind of political or or normative stance
it's a certain way of understanding what
religion is about and how it should
properly relate to politics and it's a
certain way of understanding politics
and how politics should properly relate
to religion so from the religious side I
think they're really sort of three
things that I would single out what one
of them is again kind of activism and
this is the notion that that religion
imposes a duty on believers to try to
alleviate suffering and to improve the
world in some way so it's not sort of
the world is a horrible sinful place
let's turn away from it
I'll let's retreat it into our own
communities and and wait for you know
the return of Jesus there's nothing like
that
another thing involves is a certain
measure of humility and I think this and
the in this Puritan tradition comes from
a kind of a profound sense of the
sinfulness and limitations of human
beings that though people are devoted to
trying to improve the world that the
world is in some ways a kind is not
easily moldable simply because of the
way that human beings are and the last
thing that I would emphasize is
engagement which I think follows from
the previous two which is a kind of a
willingness to open up with and
deliberate with people who think
differently with non-believers or people
who might you might consider to be
heterodox in one way or not
and that is certainly something that
comes after the Puritans because they
would not have been open to that kind of
engagement from the political side I
think I've touched on some of the main
points already but the the main thing
that I main things I would emphasize
here are an emphasis on engagement and
restraint so that we see self-government
we see self-government as an experiment
that we're engaged in collectively with
other people that requires us to sort of
open up and deliberate with people but
also to be restrained and civil in our
deliberations with those other people so
in some civil religion as I understand
it is a certain way of understanding the
relationship between religion and
politics it has a certain understanding
of the way in which religious
institutions and political institutions
and community should relate to one
another it's also refers to a certain
kind of tradition within American
politics
and finally it's a certain kind of
ethical or normative position that we
take in our dealings with others in
politics so can you give us some
examples of civil religion that we might
see today I can and the one that I would
point to actually is a presidential
campaign of Barack Obama which is what
actually got me interested and looking
at this subject and reexamining it again
here I would point in particular to the
speech on race that he gave in in
Philadelphia following the uproar around
the gerra that Jeremiah Wright tapes you
may remember that the the opening line
of that speech which was delivered at
the convention the content of the
Constitution Center in Philadelphia was
taken directly from the preamble of the
Constitution we the people of the United
States in order to to form a more
perfect union and immediately the place
and the the
the the Oratory already evokes two of
the most sacred things within American
history the the Constitution which is
one of the two most sacred documents in
American political history and of course
this is taking place across the street
from Independence Hall where the
Constitution was actually written none
of which I'm sure was was a coincidence
and what he's talking about then is a
more perfect more perfect union between
between the races and was interesting
here is that he immediately shifts
within a few lines in the speech also to
into a kind of a Puritan register as
well here echoing Abraham Lincoln's
second inaugural address and also the
writings of Frederick Douglass
he talks about the Constitution as as a
document that was flawed by what he
calls the the stain of the original sin
of slavery and so using this very
explicitly religious language which also
sort of evokes this notion of a covenant
that's unfulfilled that that there was a
certain kind of political covenant that
was embodied in the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution a
commitment to equal rights for all
people which was then in violated
immediately by the recognition of
slavery in the Constitution three-fifths
rule so on and so forth
now what's interesting here though is
that he's not just evoking the language
of of American civil religion there is
important way in which he is also
broadening and transforming it it's
important to remember here that neither
the Puritans nor the founding fathers
were exact or exactly Emancipation s or
abolitionists certainly you know
Jefferson you know for whatever you know
his personal dalliance is and history
may have been was no champion of
race-mixing in fact had you know some
rather shocking things to say actually
about both African Americans and Native
Americans and the same thing could be
said actually about many of the most
prominent Puritan preachers and
intellectuals and mathers for example
who were also not proto abolitionist by
any means so there's a way in which what
he's doing here is he's he's going back
to these original values that are
embodied in the Constitution and he's
saying that this is the sort of an
unfolding experiment in which were sort
of trying to live up to the promises
that we made at the founding of the
United States perhaps not fully
understanding exactly what it was that
we were promising and that's another
sense in which I think this is a bit
like the the covenant in the Bible that
this was sort of an unfolding
relationship a sort of unfolding
agreement between the ancient Israelites
and and their God so I guess what this
this makes clear is that there is also a
kind of a political dimension to the
project to I'm you know given that the
civil religion seems to be making a
comeback as one way of understanding how
politics and religion should be related
in the United States I think it's
important that that we begin to reflect
on what that tradition is how has
changed over time and what would be a
defensible version of civil religion in
contemporary in the contemporary United
States which is more religiously and
culturally diverse than ever and that I
think actually is one of the great
challenges in thinking about civil
religion that is that civil religion can
no longer be just a kind of a minimal
watered down kind of Protestantism or or
even monotheism it has to be something
that can embrace believers and
unbelievers alike the yesenin theose
alike and that's also part of what I'm
trying to think through right
on this project okay let's talk a little
bit about the history how did the term
civil religion originated the person who
coined the term civil religion is the
French political philosopher
jean-jacques Rousseau in the social
contract and the way in which it then
really entered into into kind of social
science discourse is through through the
work of Robert Bellah emeritus professor
of sociology at the University of
California Berkeley who wrote a very
famous essay called the American civil
religion in 1967 which provoked an
enormous uproar that lasted lasted for
twenty years and which maybe I'm in a
way trying to stir up again mm-hmm what
is it about civil religion that
interests here why are you studying it
researching it
well full disclosure part of it is that
Robert Bellah was was my doctoral
adviser and I think it was because of
having gotten to know his thinking and
having read a lot of his writings on
civil religion when I was a graduate
student that when I heard Obama speaking
in the race speech and other speeches
you know I heard the echoes of King and
Kennedy I heard the echoes of Lincoln
and Douglas and I immediately connected
it to this tradition of American
American civil religion but of course
it's not the only reason there are lots
of interesting things to work on
you know from purely scholarly point of
view and one of the reasons I want it
chose to work on this instead of some
other projects right now is because I do
see civil religion as one way possibly
instead of resources that we might use
to overcome the the kind of stark
divides of the culture wars that have so
split the united states politically over
the last 20 or 25 years and returning to
a kind of a vital center you know to
some sort of deeper moral consensus that
might allow America
to come together again to solve some of
the really serious problems that
confront us at at there at the present
moment and I think it's important again
you know as a scholar to bring you know
whatever knowledge and resources I have
to bear into that try to make the
contribution to sort of understanding
that concept of civil religion okay and
you have a new theory you're working on
how does it differ or expand upon the
current thinking around civil religion
well there are really sort of two sets
of theorists that one has to be in
conversation with if one talks about
civil religion there's on the one hand
political philosophers a point
especially to Plato Machiavelli and or
so and then there are social scientists
and here besides Robert Bellah I would
point to the late 19th century French
sociologist Emile Durkheim and my
position is a little bit different than
than all of theirs so let's start with
Plato Plato wrote three blueprints for a
kind of ideal Republic there's of course
the Republic but also the Statesman and
the laws and in all three of those works
he saw some kind of state established
obligatory cult as being an integral
ingredient to Republican self-government
as he understood it in fact he went so
far as to say that refusal to
participate in that cult should lead to
punishment possibly even to possibly
even to death if someone was
sufficiently recalcitrant now obviously
I would call that not civil religion
that Civic religion that's an
understanding of the relationship
between religion politics which sees in
a way religion as being subservient to
the ends of the state and really not
even different in a way from from the
state
Machiavelli is often seen as another
sort of big figure and the in the
development of civil religion but he has
not surprising the more Machiavelli in
take on what role religion should play
in supporting self-government he sees it
as perhaps a necessary evil as a
convenient instrument that can be used
by rulers or ruling classes to instill
certain virtues in in the masses so you
know self-discipline and bravery and so
on and so forth and again this sort of
purely instrumental relationship almost
kind of hypocritical relationship is not
one that I would sort of morally morally
espouse finally there's were so who
coins the term but he's really almost
what his vision is kind of a sort of a
platonic neo civic religion so what he
argues for is again a kind of a state
established obligatory called is the
kind of a watered-down deism is what he
actually actually has in mind with
similar penalties of people who are
nonconformist being expelled so really
where I part ways with all of these
traditions is and vociferously defending
the rights of conscious and of religious
freedom which I see as integral integral
to what the United States has been as as
as an experiment and as a democracy and
really in some ways I see the rights of
consciousness the fount of all
understandings of Rights the rights to
free speech the right to assembly these
are all things which in a way are
implied by by the rights of conscious
when they're really fully understood
what about the two social scientists
Durkheim and Bela Durkheim is like many
European intellectuals of his generation
was at a profit of secularization he
imagined that religion would necessarily
appear as modernity unfolded
unfortunately he was or fortunately he
was wrong about that depending on your
point of view I think it's us is a very
modern society but it's not at least in
terms of the convictions of its of his
citizens a particularly secular society
on the contrary and it's not at all
clear that that the rest of the world is
going more the way of secular Europe I
think actually the United States is
probably more the model for what the
religious world to look like years from
now so that's his vision was that civil
religion would replace traditional
religion but that was based on the
assumption that traditional religion was
going away which I think has turned out
to poo has proven to be incorrect
now Robert Bellah certainly did not
share in this view that secularization
would triumph that religion would
disappear but he was in many ways still
very much informed by by Durkheim
believing in a way that every society to
be a cohesive society had to have some
kind of central moral consensus around
which around which it would cohere and
he argued that civic religion was that
consensus within within the United
States where I think he perhaps went a
little bit off path was and not seeing
that there are the rival ways of
thinking about how religion and politics
should be related that it played an
enormous role in in American history and
I've already alluded to two of them one
of them is liberal secularism and or
total separation ISM and this is the
notion that religion politics absolutely
shouldn't absolutely shouldn't mix
religious arguments have no place in the
public realm religious actors have no
place in public life religious symbols
have no place in public spaces
and this view was already there in
Jefferson's lis writings its Jefferson
after all who invents this famous phrase
about the the wall of separation between
church and state which then becomes kind
of a lens which a lot of thinking about
legal thinking about church and state
then is shaped during the during the
second half of the 20th century another
one is that's very important is
religious nationalism and by this I mean
the view that the u.s. is and should be
a Christian nation and the sort of
implicit view the people who are not
Christians or and even Christians of a
particular kind have no place in the
United States and I think one of the
more remarkable statements in this line
is a statement made by George W Bush
some years ago when I asked whether he
thought an atheist could be a good
America and he expressed very serious
doubts and there are sort of more
strident versions of this that are very
much out there and alive in certain
conservative Christian circles you know
people who really believe that the only
way to sort of restore the health of the
United States is to kind of completely
Christianize it again they're even
extremely radical though fringe versions
of this that people refer to as the ahna
me which believe that that the United
States notes it has to be subjected to
Old Testament biblical law you know
adulterers have to be stoned and you
know the whole nine yards this is very
much of a fringe view but as sort of a
softer version of this that somehow
there's no place for non-believers or
non-christians of a particular kind
within the United States is very much
out there and I see civil religion as as
a way of perhaps our bridging and
overcoming this conflict between liberal
secular and religious nationalists which
I think my view is a lot of what the
cultural Wars of the last 25 years have
really been about okay well thank you
very much professor course
for sharing some of your research with
us thank you for more information about
professor Gorski and his research please
visit our website at Yale edu backslash
Macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another segment of the
Macmillan report made possible by the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale